when you think you've seen it all
you haven't quite seen it all
you have a prepaid call from
[Music]
there's an innocent man in prison
everybody's from the zoo
the tiger king 2 trailer is here and
it's full of big cats and big drama
tiger king changed our lives overnight
love's a winner
we have more money than god right now so
nobody loves me
the follow-up to 2020's wildly popular
docu-series will premiere november 17th
on netflix
jeff lowe and his wife lauren are back
not over so are tim stark alan glover
and james garrison but when it comes to
joe exotic well we'll hear from him via
the phone because he's currently behind
bars serving a 22-year sentence after
being convicted of trying to hire two
different men to kill fellow big cat
lover carol baskin
what happened to don lewis carol knows
something
he was dealing with some shady
characters down in costa rica i don't
like to play with dentures
i'll kill you for that
the question what happened to carol's
ex-husband still remains and we may not
get answers largely because carol will
not be featured in the follow-up doc
what do you have to say to the critics
out there of you find something to do
that's worthwhile with your life
spending time worrying about what i'm
doing is probably not a real good use of
your time the big cat rescue ceo has
publicly denounced the series telling
the hollywood reporter in a statement
that she's refusing to be played again
and adding that she feels the original
documentary felt like quote such a
betrayal and false portrayal
the plot to kill carol was built on
lives these people are going down you
think this was waco come get me
[ __ ]
[Music]
we gotta put our differences
aside in here
[Music]
instead carol will be featured in her
own two-part series carol baskin's cage
fight also premiering next month but on
discovery plus but back to tiger king 2
seems we've only scratched the tip of
the iceberg when it comes to conflict
and drama
chimps start
two peas in a pot when it comes to bat
crazy tim's so paranoid they had booby
traps and security cameras nobody's
going to take my animals it's that
simple there's also this
what's the nature of the dispute between
you and mr love
adios joe
very personal
back in april et spoke exclusively with
joe exotic from inside the federal
medical center in fort worth texas the
58-year-old opened up about how the term
tiger king has changed for him
tiger king meant something now it's
nothing but
porn sex sleaze and trash because jeff
lowe and lauren lowe can't get on tv
enough about their sexual habits and
and the producers of pocket king have to
pay people to to help crap and
just drama it has nothing to do
pirating the the series
and tiger king 2 could do so much to
help animals in cages
to help the preservation of tigers to
help children and and homeless people
around the world but they turned it into
crap i don't even want to tie the tiger
king anymore even though it's my
trademark it means nothing